this morning in our saturday sessions
kathleen edwards
it's a triumphant return for the
canadian singer-songwriter six years
after she abruptly quit music and opened
a coffee shop
you'll hear songs from her new album in
a moment but first edwards talked with
our anthony mason
about her decision to walk away and what
brought her back
i've got ways to make you sorry start my
life with
someone else with songs like back to me
kathleen edwards was one of the most
acclaimed young songwriters on the indie
scene
in the early 2000s
by 2012 her fourth album voyager
climbed to number 39 her highest
charting album yet
[Applause]
[Music]
on the surface it looked like you were
riding pretty high
yeah but it it didn't feel that way and
i just thought because i
i don't feel good about myself and i
don't feel good about the work i've done
so maybe i just need to
take you know take a left-hand turn here
then edwards did the
unthinkable she walked away from music
and went to get help were you relieved
when you were diagnosed with clinical
depression
oh yeah i mean it just suddenly gave a
name to
all the things i couldn't seem to
overcome the singer
went home to canada to the small town of
stittsville ontario
and opened a coffee shop fittingly
called
quitters and initially i just thought
well you know coffee shop is not a
serious thing
and then before you know it you've been
open for 20 you know for two years you
have over 20 employees
and it gave me a sense that i actually
do something else besides writing music
and there was no point
in those in the first few years that you
missed music
not at all i was thrilled
to not have to pack my suitcase i was
thrilled to not have to put on makeup
every day and
get on stage and perform i mean
it was it was so nice to have something
else to do
and so it went until last year
when singer maren morris reached out and
asked edwards to
make me collaborate i'm wanted for
nothing
she accepted the invitation and
something happened i dipped my toe in
the water and it just went ah
oh remember that oh that was really good
after eight years edwards started
writing again
the joy of making music returned and a
new album
emerged even amidst the coronavirus
so are you a coffee shop owner who sings
or
a singer who owns a coffee shop i am a
singer who can't go on tour
and play in a club and i'm a coffee shop
owner and i can't let people come into
my cafe
so i'm i've kind of really chosen the
two things
um professionally as a small business
entrepreneur that's you know i've really
chosen poorly for the covid crisis
[Laughter]
it's true